today's topic I'm gonna read you guys a
Facebook post I stumbled on yeah and
it's like part of this group okay the
name of the group this funny I only
joined it because I laugh at the things
they post but it's essentially like men
overestimate how valuable they are
that's the name of the group I'm not kid
you not so you know I had to claim an
over I'm not making this unless Lily's
anything would be good no it's actually
been snark here it's like men are
confused about their market value
something like that I can't I kid you
not so you know what joined it right now
like well it's got like 10,000 members
you know I want to join this okay okay
so but there is one post I thought was
interesting it said hi all the other day
my boyfriend told me that he isn't happy
with my current weight and that he's
struggling to be attracted to me he said
it nicely and didn't mean to hurt my
feelings but it really sucked to hear I
told my friends and they completely
freaked out and told me to leave him do
you guys agree I love him so much but I
will be honest and say that I am
terrified that no one would ever love me
again if we broke up what should I do
I'm trying to lose weight but I really
struggle so there's two parts there's
what she said and then there's the
reaction with the comments below and
what their advice was this is a tough
one but I personally could never be with
someone who sees my weight as a deciding
factor in whether or not they're
attracted to me what if you stay
together long-term and you get pregnant
would he end up cheating
what main point what i'ma read to you
guys another one I'm sorry but I might
hit him with a I was hoping your member
might get bigger true or not that is not
okay to say that a woman you love really
really is what we're doing we're getting
petty like this hit of gotta here take
everything you own and get the [ __ ] out
you deserve to be loved in your current
body in whatever version it involves too
from here yeah love has nothing to do
with physical attractive attraction
those are two separate things you can be
physically attracted to someone you love
and you can be not physically attracted
someone you love but I think most of us
want a relationship while we're
physically attracted to our partner
sit down a talk he sounds immature he
found immature do people not realize how
hard it is to go to someone you love and
to tell them something that difficult do
you not know how much you feel like
garbage prime to say but it is the truth
and it doesn't change the fact it's hard
I guarantee this guy went through a lot
of difficulty to say this stuff that's
why he was so nice about it because he
was trying to find the easiest way to
tell you without hurting you as much but
he knows it's gonna hurt anyways so I
tell him to [ __ ] off he's the one and
you were expected to spend your entire
life together then did he expect you to
stay exactly the same forever then
there's a big difference between gaining
10 20 pounds and gaining almost 100
pounds large difference large difference
no it's like emotional needs there's
plenty of times where women are talking
about the fact that their significant
other their husbands don't do certain
things for them that they used to do
don't we talk nope how about that oh he
doesn't take me out like used to oh he
doesn't and what do these women say I'm
not getting what I need so I need to
talk to him about it right that's the
exact same thing he did yeah isn't it
yeah you know how YouTube treats us okay
so be sure to hit that like button
because it helps us out with the
all-comers right you know I mean leave a
little algorithm comment let's get it
going good people if you like this
sweater we have it on our merchandise I
know a lot of you been wanting to bite
we'll check the merchandise in the
description below patreon for the
podcast let's go let's get it I see that
50% of you are watching but not
subscribed hit that Bell button make
sure you don't miss any of our daily
ring-a-ling ring a ling ling ding a ling
a ling ding dong demonic a knitting a
ding ding dong ding ding dong ring a
ling a ding ding dong Shum along a ding
dong ok whatever was it
yeah but yeah M night Shyamalan M night
Shyamalan be know you being attracted by
someone else is someone being attracted
by someone else is not something with
necessarily control okay he's being
really honest with you about the
situation this is if the city to hear
absolutely you might be struggling with
with losing weight is hard to lose what
okay it is to serve people is very hard
to lose weight if you can't wait for a
different type of reason because you're
you could gain weight because you
hormones you can be gained way because
of what you eat gateway because of the
pill
yeah the pill can get me so I it's like
it's crazy to hear it's nothing it is
gonna hurt your feelings
and a couple you're supposed to
communicate and that was what he did and
he said it nicely you said it yourself
he said it nicely so you know he didn't
say that to hurt you he said that
because that is the that's what he feels
in a healthy couple you should be
talking about those things and you
should be talking about what you feel
whether you feel attracted or not and it
happens and of course the time it can
happen it can definitely happen so
ladies sometimes the worst people you
should ask advice too is your friends
shut the [ __ ] up I got a problem with
with women talking about your
relationship if you got a prom with your
relationship you should talk to your
partner about that don't talk to
everybody why is it a bad idea to go
your it's a bad idea because there it's
one-sided and you're only gonna talk
about the bad side of things so what
happened is that when you come to us if
you're in friends okay
and you turn about your significant
other and you stay there the only thing
we remember is you talking [ __ ] we don't
have the good things we just hear you
[ __ ] so we ponder under why are you
still there why are you still suffering
this and you said that previously
whatever you tell the story you always
set it up as you being the hero you
being they you know I mean the good
person good person and keep in mind all
the comments below or email like leave
them they only have that little bit of
information and their first reaction is
kill the relationship doesn't that
strike you as odd that you're operating
on such limited information and you
think this thing should end that you
should quit on his part it's not as the
other part it's just a thing that happen
you see whenever there's something that
happen in a couple sometime it's not the
fault of neither it's not the fault of
someone is just things that are
happening but he was decent enough to
talk about it you understand what I'm
saying but it's just
that the man that you wit don't know how
you feel about sheep well we don't know
that he doesn't know he might know she
might have told him she's just still
looking for counsel oh I see what you're
saying
fine we're cool at the end of the day
all those people that you consult are
not gonna live with the consequences of
your app of what you're gonna choose to
do so that's why you should talk to him
yeah so here's the thing right he didn't
come to you with an ultimatum he didn't
come to you saying I'm going to leave
you if you don't do this what are you
saying however is there's a difficulty
within this relation amic that's making
it hard for me to feel the way I felt
about you before physically at least and
the only way to remedy that is to have
that conversation so in reality he was
just honest and forthcoming that's more
you can really hope for in a
relationship it strikes me as odd that
you would think that these things are
immutable
you met him one way if he gained 900
pounds would you still feel and to be
fair I went actually looked at her
pictures she gained a substantial amount
of weight I'm not talking about 20 or 30
pounds I'm talking 60 80 pounds so I
could understand why somebody would feel
that way I could understand it's
important if you get in a business
partnership with somebody and they
promise to do this XYZ and then all of a
sudden they stop doing all the things
that they said that they were gonna do
it's important to talk to them be like
hey you're not pulling your weight this
is a problem for this dynamic I don't
see how this is any different is it it's
not threatening the person it's not say
if you do not do it's not that as like
hey this is hard for me now on the flip
side I could understand why she is hurt
by this and I've seen you know be when
you when you are substantial overweight
I can understand it with yourself esteem
and one line that stuck out to me she
said I'm afraid that no one will ever
love me I can understand that but you
also have to acknowledge that that's
something that you have inside you in
regards to your self-esteem that's not
his fault there's not nobody else's
fault
that's your feelings towards yourself
you know and however you've lived life
so something that you need to address
personally it's not because he's gonna
stay with you regardless of your weight
that that issues gonna go away when I
looked at this it just struck me as a
little bit odd that everyone's like this
man's the devil he's gonna just drop you
in thinks no he's just expressing to you
how difficult it is there's people who
are in relation
chips where someone becomes disabled all
right or someone gets a deadly disease
and you see them try to make it work for
years in years and years and but
eventually it still breaks apart I know
someone like that personally it was hard
for them to reconcile the fact that they
couldn't be physically involved with
their partner ever we're gonna try to
maintain it and eventually they had to
have a mutual parting because a girl
recognized it was killing him
and he also recognized her we have or
wants and needs in relationship right
and sometimes if those things are met it
could really hurt us long-term you know
like your life is a huge proponent for
how successful your relationship is
likely to be if you have a terrible one
the odds of you sticking it out or
statistically way lower I don't know to
me I just I remember reading this and I
sympathize with the girls I understand
why she felt bad yeah but what other
alternative is there eat that man baby
out of your life my partner has loved me
through mental illness Wayne gain weight
gain meds etc don't settle for anything
less yes this man didn't say he stopped
loving her he saying he's struggling was
still being attracted to her and she's
been in this state for a long time yeah
if you get a mental illness I hope your
partner would intimate to you how
they're feeling about the whole scenario
without trying to give you an ultimatum
to me this is crazy bro the last thing I
what I'd like to say about this and I
would like to add is really this you see
why we don't open up for you see what
happens when we open up you see what
happened in a respectful and in a
respectful manner you see what happened
when we opened up and we decided to set
the shut up yes
it's like he opened up and this is about
to backfire because of her friends you
see why we I'm done we're all entitled
to love but we're not all entitled to be
found attractive by people and by
everybody same way we're entitled to our
rights doesn't mean that everyone has to
like and respect us
sometimes you're a dislikable person and
sometimes you're physically unattractive
yeah that's the truth body positivity
about you loving yourself doesn't mean I
gotta go out of my way to love you the
way you are I'm not going to tell you
anything but within the confines of a
relationship where you're saying we're
monogamous if we have all these needs
for each other we're gonna know it makes
sense to me that you talk to your
partner when you're not happy with
something I don't know maybe I'm missing
am i missing it I don't know bro and I'm
missing it maybe we are maybe we are
maybe we maybe Bob maybe we're not
reasonable but the thing that maybe were
immature yeah but the thing that
happened maybe you're a madman baby I
need to meet to out of my life she said
you that man baby out of our life curl
these buggin yeah it is what it is okay
this is a perfect example what why we
don't open up because that's getting
backfire you see this exact how many
women do you know who's left a man cuz
he lost all his money plenty man play me
play me play me play me man and if you
want to leave a man you know because he
does I'm not gonna get mad at you you
know I mean til death do us part or
until you get broke whatever it's all
good I get it you want to leave a man
because he no longer is able to provide
financial stability great maybe you're
not able to provide full stability it's
not that it's just no I wouldn't say she
came surely she could provide it's just
it doesn't do it for him it doesn't mean
that she cannot put up she cannot put
out but it doesn't provided for him at
the end of the day maybe we're wrong
right and the same guy the poor guy can
provide you with some burgerking
but it doesn't provide you for your
fantasy we need wants and needs fair
okay so it is very similar if you come
into this and you're saying I need this
you're not delivering I'm gonna leave
what's wrong with the opposite now he'd
even say he was going to leave or if he
just said I'm displeased with the
current situation if we're wrong we
might be we might be immature we might
be all of that we might be you know man
whatever man baby lease we might be we
might be petty we might be all of that
all of the above if so tell us why don't
be like oh you're wrong that's dumb
that's dumb that's not further the
conversation but go ahead we might be
wrong but from what I see it
[Music]
you